[Music]
you know I I recently
um I reread that email that you sent
like 3 years
ago you
did you didn't say anything man you just
stared at me said that's what you should
do right
now and I
[Music]
just I just want
to I
[Music]
just I just want to say sorry for the
way I reacted to
[Music]
that
because
I I'm kind of ashamed of my my response
to that because reading that now I see
that you were saying that you just
wanted to experience
friendship and I just kind of gave you
my perspective back to try to explain
the way that I felt about it and and
really kind of tried to defend myself
but I didn't take the time to
acknowledge your need in what you were
saying and validate that and I
just I just feel like an
[__]
I'm
sorry you should
be I don't remember what I said it was
it it was pretty moving at the time and
I did cry and it was real I did cry so
it it did take two two years to get like
a full closure on it yeah it it's
interesting cuz I thought we this wasn't
it and and now and
now celebrating our 40th year of
friendship yes seems like 40 but it's
only 39 when you have when good things
are happening they seem
[Music]
longer